[Music]
I think the statute of limitations has
passed on telling stories out of school
so I'm gonna do this one it's 12 years
ago or so since when he came one day he
was at Cornell had been a student of
Francis Lowe and one day he called me up
and he said he really wanted to come
back to MIT we weren't looking for
anyone at the time really wanted to come
back then why do you hope you'll forgive
me Alan and he knew that he was too old
to come in as an assistant professor and
he'd be willing to take the risk of
coming back at a level where where the
risk of tenure comes sooner I brought
her up with the theory group with the
higher energy group and we we knew that
it was a difficult kind of situation but
we did it anyway we took the risk well
here's our risk you can put the right
first line of my way
those who know me and know that I
usually have a my title transparency
cartoon of a well-known cartoon
character but the organizers of this
talk of this of this conference took the
precaution of having all the speakers
sign affidavits saying that they
actually had obtained the right to use
all of the visuals that they used during
their talks so sorry folks no cartoon
will have to do without that I'm gonna
be talking about some of the impact that
modern particle physics has had on
cosmology as you probably know a small
drove of particle theorists began to
dabble in cosmology back in the late
1970s and I became part of that drove a
lot of our colleagues felt we were
motivated mainly by jealousy of Carl
Sagan but but I've always maintained
that there was also a significant
motivation which stems from developments
and particle physics itself and what I
have in mind of course is the advent of
grand unified theories these theories
were first invented back in 1974 but it
wasn't really until the late 1970s that
they really began to become objects of
widespread interest in the particle
theory community what makes these
theories important for cosmology is that
they make their most important
predictions at an energy scale of about
10 to the 14 or 10 to the 15 GeV by the
standards of our local power company
that's not much energy it's about what
it takes to light a hundred watt light
bulb for a minute but as you might
imagine having that much energy on a
single elementary particle is of course
extraordinary one could imagine trying
to build an accelerator that would reach
those energies one could take for
example the Stanford Linear Accelerator
and imagine scaling it up the output
energy is essentially directly
proportional to the length so it's a
back-of-the-envelope calculation to
figure out how long slack would have to
be in order to reach an energy of 10 to
the 14 GeV the answer in case you've
never done this calculation it turns out
to be almost exactly 1 in the right
units the units of course being light
years so
needless to say the Department of Energy
and NASA have both been very reluctant
to entertain proposals to build such an
accelerator and what that means is that
if we want to be able to see the most
dramatic consequences of these grand
unified theories we're really forced to
turn to the only laboratory to which we
have any access at all which has ever
reached these energies and that appears
to be the universe itself in its very
infancy and that basically is the reason
why so many particle theorists have
become interested in the early universe
could have the next transparency what I
want to do in today's talk since I now
have a very interesting experimental
result that came out just a few weeks
ago the Cobie results
I'd like to basically spend the
beginning part of the talk building up
to a discussion of Cobie and then I will
try to discuss the implications of the
Cobie measurements so I need to begin by
discussing the standard hot Big Bang
Theory and I know that many of you are
nuclear physicist and particle
physicists and have not considered much
about what's about the details of
cosmology so I have here a complete
summary of the important elements of the
standard Big Bang Theory in three
statements the first statement is the
assumption that the early universe was a
uniformly expanding extremely hot gas
which was in thermal equilibrium or at
least approximately in thermal
equilibrium at all times during the
expansion so the expansion is just the
adiabatic expansion of a thermal
equilibrium gas something which of
course we've all learned how to treat in
our stat mech courses in the early
universe the mass density we believed
was completely dominated by blackbody
radiation not by the matter that now
dominates the mass of the universe and
that makes it of course a very simple
treatment to a very simple system to
treat all of the properties of this gas
are completely determined once you know
the temperature and you can calculate
how fast the temperature changes because
you can calculate the dynamics of the
expansion and cooling the third
assumption is what makes that
calculation possible the assumption that
the only significant force in the early
universe is the force of gravity which
is gradually slowing down the expansion
due to the gravitational attraction of
everything for everything else this of
course in cosmology is generally tree
using general relativity but in fact you
can use Newton's laws of mechanics and
they work almost as well and in many
cases give identical answers next
transparency okay so much for standard
cosmology now we'll move right along and
get into the topic of inflation because
that what I'd like to do is to explain
some of the consequences of inflation
and to what extent they've been tested
by the Cobie measurements so I want to
explain to you the mechanism behind
inflation because I think it all seems
very mysterious if one doesn't have some
notion of how inflation works so I'd
like to go through this reasonably
quickly inflation is driven by a scalar
field and the first thing I want to
point out is that scalar fields are very
commonplace to all particle theorists
there are essential ingredients of the
glasha one works a law model of electro
weak interactions they're also an
essential ingredient of grand unified
theories the modern super string
theories do not have fundamental scalar
particles in fact they do not have
fundamental particles at all the
fundamental ingredients in those
theories are strings but nonetheless
even in these theories at energies well
below the Planck scale of 10 to the 19
GeV the theories are believed to be well
approximated by our good old fashioned
quantum field theories in which one has
real particles and in fact the
superstring theories always give rise to
a reasonably large number of what
appeared to be fundamental scalars in
this low-energy approximation next
transparency it is typical of a Higgs
field that the potential energy function
has a minimum at some value other than
zero
now the field that drives inflation is
actually almost certainly not the Higgs
field of either the Weinberg Selam model
or the Higgs field of the grand unified
theory but nonetheless it is patterned
on that model so I will assume that the
minimum energy of the scalar field is at
some nonzero value here called Phi sub T
T for true vacuum remember the
definition of the vacuum in this context
is simply the state of lowest possible
energy density so that is by definition
then the vacuum however the potential
energy function could also somewhere
else have a plateau or perhaps another
minimum that can be a metastable state
that is if the plateau is gentle enough
it can take a very long time before a
scalar field perched on top of that
plateau can find its way to roll down
the hill especially by the timescales of
the early universe it is that metastable
state which is called a false vacuum
that is a false vacuum is simply a state
where in some region of space where the
scalar field has the value that you're
called Phi sub F the value at the top of
the plateau the energy that is then
dominated by this scalar field and the
energy density I will call Rho sub F F
for false vacuum next transparency I try
to explain here where the word false
vacuum comes from it may be more or less
obvious by now a vacuum is being used in
the sense of state of lowest possible
energy density this clearly is not the
state of lowest possible energy density
the scalar field could roll down the
hill and find the bottom but the
assumption is that that takes a long
time so temporarily this acts as if the
energy is already as low as it can get
so we have as a temporary vacuum and the
word false is being used to denote that
notion of temporal temporariness now
just knowing the fact that the energy
density of this false vacuum cannot be
lowered at least on an appropriate time
scale that's all one needs to actually
derive what is it it's crucial property
for cosmology which is its pressure we
can derive its pressure by doing a
thought experiment
don't try to actually do this experiment
by the way it's very expensive
not to mention difficult but let's
imagine that we have a piston chamber
that we filled with a false vacuum with
this non zero energy density and a
pressure which we're trying to calculate
outside we just have ordinary vacuum so
the energy density is zero and the
pressure is zero what I want to imagine
is that somebody pulls out on the
plunger enlarging the volume of the
chamber inside by an amount DV now since
the energy density is fixed because the
scalar field just has no lower energy
state to go to that it can reach in the
appropriate amount of time the energy
density inside this chamber will remain
constant which is obviously something
that's very different
from any ordinary material that we are
used to if there was a gas inside that
nitrogen it would just thin out as you
increase the volume but a false vacuum
cannot do that and that's what makes it
so different from any other material so
the energy density remains constant the
energy inside therefore goes up by the
energy density times the change in
volume by conservation of energy that
must be equal to the work that the
person pulling on the plunger has done
in pulling it out by that distance and
that work is just minus PDV and that
implies immediately that p has to be
equal to minus Rho sub F in other words
the false vacuum creates a suction a
negative pressure inside this piston so
that to pull it out you have to do work
the work you do is just enough so that
as you pull it out the energy density
inside remains constant so what we have
is a colossal negative pressure next
transparency okay now what is the
cosmological effect of such a negative
pressure
well one can put this into Einstein's
equations to find out what they do to a
cosmological model and what's found is
that they act exactly like Einstein's
famous cosmological constant but only
temporarily of course that is it only
acts like this as long as the false
vacuum survives and it is only
metastable not absolutely stable the
effect is to slow the cosmic expansion
well excuse me that in general the
effect of gravity is to slow the cosmic
expansion and I've written here the key
equation that describes how gravity
slows the expansion of the universe the
expansion the universe is described in
terms of a scale factor R are simply
sets the size scale for the entire
universe in the sense that whenever R
doubles it means that the entire
universe being described has doubled in
size all distances within it so it says
that the acceleration of our R double
dot is negative and proportional to G
Eden's constant times the mass density
plus 3 times the pressure the first term
is purely Newtonian it's exactly what
you get from Newtonian mechanics the
second term is what is normally a
relativistic correction in this case
however it is by no means a relativistic
correction our pressure is negative and
equal in magnitude to the energy density
so the second term dominates and
actually changes the overall sign of the
right hand side of the equation thereby
completely reversing the effect of
gravity the false vacuum actually
creates a very large gravitational
repulsion and the expansion of the
universe is accelerated if the universe
is ever in the false vacuum state rather
than having the expansion the universe
being slowed down as it normally is on
gravitational effects next transparency
okay so the key behind the inflationary
model is the assumption that the
universe went through a short period
during which the matter in the universe
was dominated by this very peculiar
state that is predicted by many many of
our particle theories the state called a
false vacuum to take you through the
scenario of the new inflationary
universe the word new here by the way as
most of you probably know is there
because the original inflationary
universe that I proposed in 1981 did not
quite work there was a flaw having to do
with the way in which inflation ended it
to not end smoothly enough the first
working version of inflation was the
so-called new inflationary model posed
independently by andrei linde and
Albrecht and Steinhardt in 1982 and what
I'll basically be describing here today
is the new inflationary universe
although now there are several other
working versions of inflation in
addition the key idea is the belief that
a small patch of the universe it doesn't
have to be the whole universe and it
doesn't have to be very large ten to the
minus 24 centimeters across will do a
small patch of the early universe
somehow settled into a false vacuum
state there are a number of ideas about
how this can happen in fact in many of
these theories this is the thermal
equilibrium state at high temperatures
so if the universe simply cools quickly
it would supercooled into one of these
false vacuum in any case once you assume
that this happens for one reason or
another everything else is really pretty
well dictated one doesn't have much in
the way of other choices beyond the
assumptions that one has to make to get
into the false vacuum and start
inflation in the first place okay then
this patch of space will start to expand
and expands exponentially and what you
need is for the false vacuum to be
sufficiently stable so that that
exponential expansion
encompasses at least twenty five orders
of magnitude it can by the way be much
more than that there's no fine-tuning is
necessary to cut that off no matter how
large that is it's okay as far as the
predictions of inflation but one does
need a number at least this large in
order for inflation to solve the
problems that it was intended to solve
during this time the particle density
then is essentially driven to zero by
the enormous exponential expansion if
there are any bumps or lumps in the
metric of space itself they are also
smoothed out by the enormous expansion
so just like the surface of the earth
always looks flat to us even though we
know it's really round any fold or band
in the metric of space gets stretched to
the point where it becomes completely
invisible to any local observation
there'll be a correlation length in this
early universe a distance over which
temperatures and particle velocities and
values of fields are correlated that's
initially very small but will be
stretched by this enormous expansion and
you need to assume that it's stretched
to a length of about 10 centimeters by
the time inflation is over this is the
size that what we now call the visible
universe would have had at the end of
inflation and that's where this number
comes from then the normal evolution of
the universe at the end of inflation
takes this size scale and stretches it
out to be the presently observed
universe okay eventually the false
vacuum decays it's only metastable not
absolutely stable
what it does it releases this colossal
energy density that produces particles
which scatter off of each other
producing more particles and very
quickly the system reaches thermal
equilibrium and what you have is a hot
soup of gas uniformly spread through
space expanding uniformly which is
exactly what it Oh has been the assumed
starting point of the standard
cosmological model so the effect of
inflation is simply to establish the
initial conditions for standard
cosmology which then takes over at this
time next transparency ah we need to
make the baryons that we see in the
universe are any baryons that might have
been present before inflation would get
diluted away by the enormous expansion
just like anything else so it is
essential in an inflationary model to
have an underlying particle physics in
which baryon number is not conserved
so that baryons can be produced after
inflation fortunately most modern
particle theories have this property so
it does not seem to be any kind of a
barrier I want to point out that if
inflation is right it means that
essentially all of the matter and energy
in the observed universe is actually
produced during this exponential
expansion and then subsequent decay
that's two works in the subsequent decay
of the false vacuum you might wonder
what happens to conservation of energy
and I thought you might so I put it on
the transparency here what happens to
conservation of energy is that it turns
out that the gravitational field itself
gives a negative contribution to the
total energy and what happens during
inflation is that more and more positive
energy appears in the form of an
enlarged region of false vacuum as the
exponential expansion takes place but at
the same time a compensating amount of
negative energy appears and the enlarged
volume of the gravitational field and
the net result is that energy is
conserved it remains constant and it
remains at all times in fact incredibly
small and it could even be exactly zero
it is quite consistent with everything
we know that the gravitational energy of
the universe might precisely cancel the
energy that we see in the form of stars
and galaxies and so on next transparency
okay you might wonder why people would
perhaps believe that inflation may have
taken place well inflation does answer
questions about a number of the
fundamental properties that the universe
has which otherwise go unexplained many
of these properties are properties that
are so obvious that people have grown to
accept them without ever feeling that
they needed to be explained but the nice
thing about inflation is that does
explain it and once one has an
explanation one becomes fond of it and
one tends to look down on other
possibilities in which the explanation
gets lost so let me just summarize what
some of these properties of the universe
are that inflation can explain the first
one is simply the bigness of the
universe the universe as you know is
really very very very big the number of
particles for example is at least as big
as 10 to the 90 which is probably about
the
largest number you're likely to come
across in physics the question is simply
where did they all come from now in the
standard cosmological model most people
probably don't realize this but you
start out assuming that all ten to the
90 of these particles are already there
the model contains no mechanism whatever
for the creation of the particles or of
the matter in any form in the
inflationary model however you don't
need that all you need is this small
patch of false vacuum which people now
hope might materialize as a quantum
fluctuation or something that's of
course still very speculative but in any
case you don't need anything like the 10
to the 9 D particles that you need in
order to start off as a standard
cosmological model of the universe the
second feature is the Hubble expansion
which of course is very well known
discovered back in 1929 inflation leads
to it naturally the exponential
expansion is driven by the repulsion of
the gravitational effects of the false
vacuum and sets the universe out in this
motion what's going on here is the basic
fact that again is not very well
publicized that the Big Bang Theory does
not in any way contain a theory of the
bang the Big Bang Theory as it was
developed in the early part of this
century is really the theory of the
aftermath of a bang without any
explanation as to what it was that
banged inflation is an answer to that
question it would be this exponential
expansion of the false vacuum that
really would be the bang of the Big Bang
third the question of homogeneity and
isotropy the universe is known to be
incredibly uniform the cosmic background
radiation which is what I'll be coming
to shortly is now known to be uniform
same temperature in all directions to
accuracies of one part in ten to the
five extreme accuracy now in the
standard cosmological model that
radiation if you look in different
directions is coming from matter which
at the time they the radiation was
emitted those different pieces of matter
had not even had time to communicate
with each other at the speed of light in
fact they missed by about a factor of a
hundred so in the standard cosmological
model there's no explanation whatever as
to why the temperature should look the
same in all directions you can make it
work in the context of the standard
model you do that by simply assuming
that the universe started out with a
completely uniform temperature
throughout but what one does not happens
model is any explanation whatever is to
how or why the universe was so uniform
in inflation that happens naturally
because one starts with an incredibly
small region of space which has had
plenty of time to come to a uniform
temperature the same way a glass of
water sitting on the table comes to a
uniform temperature and then inflation
takes over and takes this incredibly
small region and magnifies it so that it
becomes large enough to encompass the
entire observed universe ok next the
notion of what's called flatness in
cosmology that is the closeness of the
actual density of the universe to what
is called the critical density which is
that density which is just barely
sufficient to eventually halt the
expansion of the universe today we don't
know very well how close we are to the
critical density but even with the big
uncertainties in the value today when
you extrapolate it backwards and ask
what must it have come from what you
find if you extrapolate back to say one
second which is a very reasonable time
in classical cosmology it's really the
beginning of the nucleosynthesis
processes at that time what you compute
is that the density must have been equal
to the critical density to accuracies of
the order of 15 decimal places and
standard cosmology one simply has to put
that in as an assumption about the
initial conditions without any
explanation in the inflationary model on
the other hand it turns out that this
period of exponential expansion actually
drives the universe to a critical
density and doesn't in fact to a rather
extraordinary accuracy so that one has a
clear prediction and that even today the
mass density of the universe should be
at the critical density if inflation is
right finally there's magnetic monopoles
if grand unified theories are right and
standard cosmology or right it would
mean that we would just be swimming in
magnetic monopoles well in fact we
haven't detected or seen any and
inflation gets rid of them by simply
inflating them away diluting them to a
negligible density okay now I'm ready to
move on to the second part of my talk I
want to discuss the cosmic background
radiation and what we have learned about
it in particular from the Coby satellite
first I have here simply a slide of the
spectrum of the cosmic background
radiation as it was measured by Coby
this is a far
a better measurement than anything that
had preceded it
I had toyed with the idea of showing you
some of the earlier graphs just to
assure my sure that you would be
adequately impressed by the graph that
you're seeing now
I decided that maybe it wasn't worth the
time to do that but as you can see
there's an absolutely marvelous
agreement between the data points shown
as these little boxes and the black
curve which is a blackbody spectrum let
me remind you that this is only a one
parameter fit the only thing that's fit
is the temperature once you know the
temperature you know not only where the
peak should be but exactly how high the
peak should be and both agree perfectly
with the data and same with the entire
shape of the curve so we have extremely
good evidence now that the radiation
that we're seeing is remarkably thermal
and that's exactly what would be
expected from primordial radiation that
is leftover from the heat of the Big
Bang which is how this radiation is
being interpreted next transparency okay
I wanted to try to describe here exactly
where this radiation is really coming
from so what I've drawn is a spacetime
diagram of the universe I'm showing only
two dimensions of space Illustrated here
as the x and y axis and one direction of
time which is oh there is going upward
the present time is supposed to be this
dot and we can imagine that we are
sitting at the position and time of that
dot looking outward and when you look
outward what we see is light that has
been traveling from the past so our past
light cone which is basically the light
we were looking at goes downward in all
directions and the further out we look
as everybody knows the further into the
past we are looking at okay now let me
describe what's supposed to be going on
at the bottom part of this diagram which
represents the beginning of the time of
our universe the Big Bang is supposed to
be at time zero here
this gray sheet it's not that easy to
see it supposed to be a little bit above
it's not at time zero it's a little bit
later it's supposed to be actually at
300,000 years is where the gray sheet is
supposed to be now what happened at
300,000 years the key thing is that
according to cosmology the early
universe was incredibly hot actually
arbitrarily hot if you follow it
backwards towards the
the tea the theoretical T equals zero in
the model and that means that the matter
in the early universe would certainly
not have been in the form of neutral
atoms it was a plasma and until about
300,000 years after the Big Bang the
mass in the universe consisted of a
plasma of protons and free electrons and
also neutrinos and photons and so on in
this hot plasma photons are constantly
being Reece quatre de Chardin Aluva
through space and this plasma is very
dense it's an extremely dense fog from
the point of view of the radiation and
that is what it's supposed to exist
below this gray sheet the gray sheets
must be an equal time surface
representing the time of recombination
and is the time when matter became
neutral by the way this has always been
called recombination I don't think
anybody really knows why the prefix REE
is there but this is when hydrogen the
protons and the electrons combine to
form neutral atoms beyond that suddenly
the universe becomes very transparent a
neutral gas is very transparent to
radiation so we believe that the photons
that we are looking at now coming back
from along our past light cone we're
last scattered when they intersected
this sheet at the time of recombination
and this circle which would really be
the surface of a sphere if we were if I
drew a three a full three-dimensional
model this circle is called the surface
of last scattering the last time this
radiation was scattered before the
photons set off on their very long
journey which we believe was untrue
uninterrupted from then until it is now
being received by the Coby satellite
right where my red dot is currently
pointing ok next transparency now what
does inflation have to do with these
density fluctuations well at first it
appeared as if the inflation model might
give a completely uniform universe with
no non-uniform use whatever and that
would of course be at odds with our
universe these non uniformity is that
Kobe is detecting we believe are
associated with ripples in the energy
density in the early universe which are
in turn associated with the subsequent
formation of
galaxies clusters of galaxies and so on
the key point is that the universe is
gravitationally unstable if there's any
slight excess of mass in some region of
the universe that will of course create
a slightly stronger than average
gravitational field which will in turn
pull more mass in creating a still
stronger gravitational field and the
process will cascade until one develops
the complicated structure of galaxies
and clusters that we observe in the
universe today but in order to start it
all off one does need to have small
non-uniformities and the initial mass
density distribution or else no
structure forms now as I said the
inflationary model when when first
thinks about it appears to give a
completely uniform universe because what
you have is this energy density of the
false vacuum which is just fixed by the
Lagrangian that describes the false
vacuum and would be the same at all
places giving you a featureless universe
this was a topic that was much discussed
back in 1982 shortly after the invention
of the new inflationary model by Linda
and Albert Einstein Hart which brought
new interest to the idea of inflation it
was finally realized and I'm pretty sure
it was Stephen Hawking who first pointed
this out that since the world is really
quantum mechanical this classical
prediction of inflation is clearly not
the final answer in a quantum mechanical
world any classical statement is of
course really just the peak of a quantum
mechanical probability distribution
so if classical physics plus inflation
predicts a completely uniform universe
one would assume that quantum physics
plus an inflationary model would give
you small deviations about that uniform
mass density and perhaps these could be
the seeds for you Alec C formation okay
there was an a complicated series of
interchanges Stephen Hawking himself
wrote a paper about this claiming that
everything worked exactly right and that
you even got the right amplitude for the
fluctuations as well as a spectrum that
cosmologists I thought was very
plausible then a number of the rest of
us started thinking about it and we
didn't understand Stephens calculation
and we eventually were able to do our
own calculations and got an answer that
was very different from Stephens the
answer we got was that
spectrum was what Steven had said which
was a desirable result but that the
amplitude that we would get would be
about 10 to the 5 times larger than what
one actually wanted for galaxy formation
and that was course very disappointing
this whole issue came to a head in the
summer of 1982 when there was a
conference in Cambridge England which
was organized by Gibbons and Hawking
called the Nuffield workshop on the
early universe there about six people or
so they are working on this problem of
density fluctuations in the early
universe and we were all disagreeing
with each other all during the
conference but by the end of the
conference we actually did settle our
differences and come to an agreement on
what the answer is and that agreement
has stuck ever since and the answer
turned out to be the not the one that
Hawking got on for but the other one the
one that gave a number that was 10 to
the 5 times too large now what's also
true though which is crucial here is
that the amplitude of these fluctuations
it turns out to be very model dependent
very much dependent on the underlying
particle physics that one assumes and we
were all working in the context at this
point of the minimal su v grand unified
theory which at that point was far and
away the most popular idea in grand
unified theories and we realized that if
we if that model were not the case that
it would be possible to get in the
amplitude we wanted including of course
the right amplitude so we were spending
the next few years hoping that the
minimal su v grand unified theory would
go away our hopes were fulfilled
due to the marvelous proton decay
experiments it was found that the
prediction that these models made for
the proton decay lifetime were
inconsistent with observation and in
fact now nobody knows what the correct
grand unified theory is if indeed any of
them are correct so what can we said
presently is that the spectrum predicted
by inflation is about what one wants and
the amplitude is adjustable depending on
what or what elementary particle physics
one puts in to underlie the inflation
but I don't want to scribe briefly as
how one calculates density fluctuations
in these model where they really come
from in an inflationary model the scale
factor during inflation expands
exponentially the hubble constant which
turns out to be just our dot over R is
that a constant chi the
exponential expansion rate this is to be
contrasted with a radiation dominated
universe in which the scale factor grows
like the square root of time and the
Hubble constant then falls like 1 over 2
T try to remember these equations for
the next transparency next transparency
ok this diagram is more or less crucial
to understanding just the kinematics of
how density perturbations evolve which
is all I'll try to explain today first
let's look at the line that my red
pointer is now pointing to which is the
inverse Hubble constant during the
inflationary era that's constant at the
end of inflation the Hubble constant
Falls like 1 over T so the inverse
Hubble constant grows like T so the line
goes like this now the relevance of the
inverse Hubble constant is that it sets
the effect of scalar which different
things can influence each other if two
objects in the universe are separated by
the inverse Hubble constant it means
that H times their distance is 1 it
means that they're moving apart from
each other and effectively the speed of
light so things that are beyond H
inverse from each other cannot affect
each other well things that are less can
so it sets the scale of causal influence
the other line follows the wavelength of
a typical fluctuation you follow the
Fourier mode as it is stretched by the
redshift of the universe so the
wavelength just follows the scale factor
itself which rises exponentially during
inflation and then Rises like the square
root of time thereby turning over and
allowing itself to intersect the Hubble
constant curve again so the two curves
course cost twice our fluctuation starts
out very small compared to H inverse
then becomes larger than H inverse and
then comes back in inside the Hubble
radius again the notion behind the way
fluctuations arise in inflation is that
they are established at this point and
then we measure them after they come
back inside the Hubble length at much
later times the fluctuations are caused
I think I'll skip some transparencies
here to save time but the fluctuations
are caused by the non uniformity with
which the scalar field rolls down the
hill in the potential energy diagram
it's not a classical process obviously
it's a quantum process and it is
possible to really calculate
the quantum deviations in the rolling of
the scalar fuel down the hill which
leads effectively to deviations small
deviations in the time at which
inflation ends at different places and
will control this through using a
linearized approximation of general
relativity to actually calculate then
what are the density perturbations
predicted today and now I guess why I
just flashed the next few transparency
so I can tell you how many skip okay
audience don't look you're not supposed
to bother with these okay next one one
more then we'll hold the next one okay
this is the prediction the prediction is
that if you measure a Fourier mode so
it's a function of K of the perturbation
and the mass density over the mass
density the fractional perturbation of
the mass density at the time when these
waves come back inside the Hubble length
at the second Hubble crossing in that
original diagram the inflation predicts
that that should be roughly a constant
it does depend slightly on the
underlying particle physics and if you
make the underlying particle physics
very strange you can in fact make it
more or less anything you want but
almost all sensible particle physics
will give you something here which is
very nearly a constant and that's known
as a Harrison Zelda or
scale-invariant spectrum and the
probability distributions there any
given Fourier mode is completely
Gaussian this is actually dictated by
just the zero point quantum fluctuations
of a quantum field theory next
transparency okay now we can come to
what Kobe has measured and how to
compare it to this what Kobe has
effectively measured are the
fluctuations in temperature as one looks
at different angles but with reasonably
large errors on any given pixel in this
picture so it's really the data that you
get by correlating those pixels that's
relevant and not the map that you get of
the pixels themselves they've measured
it in three different wavelengths
corresponding to three point three five
point seven and nine point five
millimeters for safety sake they had two
nearly independent channels at each
wavelength so they can compare them with
each other and having three different
wavelengths of course was also used to
check their data let me point out that
when you look at blackbody radiation at
any given wavelength the
density gives you a measure of the
temperature well it doesn't have to fit
the whole curve to figure out what the
temperature is what measures the
intensity at any given wavelength and
that uniquely determines the temperature
so by having three different wavelengths
if all three temperature measurements
agreed they think they can have
confidence in the results if they differ
then they might think it's an absorption
by some molecule or something those
kinds of effects would be particular to
some frequency or another and would not
give the same temperature shift for all
three measurements the beam size is
quite large there's a 7 degree
full-width half max so Kobe is not
capable of seeing the really fine
structure in the cosmic background
radiation Kobe is only capable of seeing
the very very large-scale structure in
terms of present-day structures in the
universe this actually is a serious
limitation the clusters and the galaxies
that we see actually evolved from
perturbations that are too small to be
visible to Kobe so what Kobe is saying
is the very large wavelength end of the
spectrum of perturbations perturbations
are in fact too large in wavelength to
be directly responsible for any visible
object in the universe they were very
careful applied a lot of corrections
they even this really kind of amazes me
is the next ya they even had a correct
for the effect of the Earth's magnetic
field on their instruments after doing
all their best shielding they still
found in effect which they could
tabulate and correct for and when they
were done with all of their subtle
Corrections they obtained next
transparency a correlation function
which is the key result which they've
obtained it's the expectation value of
the temperature fluctuation at one point
times the temperature fluctuation at
another point at some particular angle
alpha and this quantity is computed for
all pairs of points on the sky and then
are averaged over all pairs of points at
a given value of alpha and then that's
plotted as a function of alpha so the
correlation function represents the
correlations and the fluctuations at a
particular angular separation between
the two points that are being looked at
on the sky the results are on the next
transparency
these are the results error bars are
shown the error bars are intended to
include both systematic and statistical
errors if the COBE people are right
once they've refined their data
correcting for systematics the way they
have they believe that most of the
residual error is and is in fact
statistical but of course there's always
the possibility of somebody discovering
a systematic error that they missed the
gray band and this is what's so
beautiful to people who've been working
on this the grey band represents the
prediction of this scale-invariant
Harrisons el de vich spectrum predicted
by inflation the reason it is a band and
not a line is that the prediction is
after all probabilistic what we are
seeing here is directly the implications
of quantum mechanics this is a real
quantum mechanical experiment if our
underlying theory is right so naturally
one does not make a decison but rather
what is predicted by the theory is a
probability distribution and the gray
band is the result of Monte Carlo
studies of that probability distribution
and represents a 68 percent confidence
level of the distribution they fit this
to a power law to see how well they can
determine this to be a scale-invariant
spectra and unfortunately error bars are
still pretty large they fit it to a
power spectrum where N equals 1 the way
they define things is the scale and
variance spectrum that's being predicted
and what they find when they do a fit to
the data is that they get an N of 1.1
plus or minus 0.5 so it's the right
answer but the error bars are too large
so they have to keep working and they
will Kobe is still in the air they have
another years worth of data which they
have yet to analyze which they certainly
will and they're still in the air
gathering more data and hopefully before
it's over they might have as much as
four years worth of data and the errors
should come down considerably next
transparency okay they have also weighed
we'll do another test what they measure
is the very long wavelength fluctuations
but we have some idea what the shorter
wavelength fluctuations are from
theories of galaxy formation those were
uncertain by maybe a factor of two but
because they're on such shorter
wavelengths that still gives you a good
handle when was trying to extrapolate
well to determine the variation of the
spectrum with wavelength so by doing
that and allowing for this uncertainty
of about a factor of two in the
amplitude at small values of the
wavelength they were able to obtain an
alternative an alternate value of n
which I believe is actually completely
independent of the first one the first
one depends on the shape of their own
data with wavelength this just depends
on taking the normalization from their
data and comparing it with short
wavelength estimates from galaxy
formation and what they get this time is
an N which is also one in fact two
slightly better accuracy 0.23 this time
and this is a measurement which
stretches over three decades of scale
they also of course I measured a
magnitude to these fluctuations they
measured a quadrupole moment which
corresponds to a fluctuation in the
temperature of five parts and a million
this exceeds the best previous bound by
about a factor of two which is very nice
the best previous bound being the result
of an MIT balloon experiment by Steven
Mayer
they've also fit the results to an
assumed scale invariant power spectrum
finding the delta T over T which differs
slightly from what they get by measuring
the quadrupole next transparency okay
now what are the implications of this
well how much time you have left by by
being able to directly see these
primordial fluctuations in the cosmic
background radiation it enables us to
ask a question which cosmologists have
always wanted to answer but have never
before had the ingredients necessary to
answer that is now that we know how
things started at least on sunland
scales we can ask do we understand how
the universe evolved from these early
conditions to the present in particular
the question tends to be given these
very small non-uniformities in the early
universe can we understand how the very
significant structures that we see in
the universe evolved well the answer
turns out to be yes under some
assumptions and no under others and
that's very important because it helps
us single out the theories of structure
formation that have the possibility of
doing the job so far of course the
choice is by no means unique
but a number of possibilities have been
ruled out in particular one rather
staggering result but which appears to
be valid I'm sorry I have to start at
the beginning with the caveat the caveat
is important in order to ask how
structure evolved from the primordial
fluctuations one has to look at the
fluctuations on the same scale as the
structure and as I mentioned earlier
those those are unfortunately not really
the scales that Kobe is looking at Kobe
is looking at much longer wavelengths so
if one makes no extrapolations and just
tries to work with the raw Kobe data as
its measured one essentially has nothing
to say about how structure in the
universe could have evolved because
those structures involved from from
shorter wavelength primordial
fluctuations so all the implications
really hinge on being willing to make
the assumption that the scale invariant
spectrum which Kobe sees can be
extrapolated down to shorter wavelengths
and then looking at the shorter
wavelengths one can ask can we
understand how those very small
deviations in the early universe evolved
to become the present-day structure so
everything that I have to say here is
based on that one very important
assumption okay if you make that
assumption then one immediately gets a
very remarkable results all known models
in which the mass density is dominated
by baryonic matter matter that's made
out of protons and neutrons appear to be
ruled out okay the problem is that
baryonic matter couples rather strongly
two photons right up until the time that
the matter becomes electrically neutral
this recombination then it just turns
out there's not enough time for the
matter - then clump if it was that
smooth at the time of recombination on
the other hand in these models of dark
matter in which the dark matter is
assumed to be very weakly interacting
that dark matter would not be strongly
interacting with the radiation and it
would start to clump long before the
time of recombination giving itself a
head start so if the dark matter
theories are right the early universe at
the time that Kobe is looking at it was
not nearly as smooth as what Kobe is
seeing but Kobe is saying a very smooth
result because it looks only at the
photons Wow if the dark matter was not
interacting with the photons it could
have been significantly more clumped and
would have been even
so a strong indication that what we have
in the universe is some form of
nonbaryonic matter still of course a big
mystery what exactly that matter is
likely to turn out to be they also
looked at a number of specific models
for example they looked at cold dark
matter models both with large Hubble
constants and small Hubble constants
with a large Hubble constant which is
what's discussed here it does not work
it turns out that there's just not
enough time for structure to form if you
start out with a I'm sorry I got that
wrong in this model it actually works
the other way with a large Hubble
constant in a cold dark matter model too
much structure forms if one assumes the
initial conditions as indicated by Coby
next transparent next and final
transparency ok listed here are three
models which appear to work so as you
see the field does not narrow down very
well yet what is a very attractive model
to most people working in theoretical
cosmology is a cold dark matter model
with a low Hubble constant Agua constant
of 50 and the astronomers units of
kilometers per second per megaparsec
this is about a lowest value as can be
tolerated given observations and some
people will say it cannot be tolerated
but some people say that about
everything the model gives a very good
fit to structure on a very wide range of
scales the only thing in structure that
does not account for is one observation
of very large structure on scales of
about a hundred megaparsecs seen in a
study known as the APM study this is yet
to be confirmed so it's not that clear
if a correct model should fit it many
structures have been seen in the
universe and have later gone away with
more careful studies there also is
perhaps a problem on very short length
scales on very short length scales the
problems the calculations become very
hard to do because things become very
nonlinear the people's best estimates
give a contradiction on very short
length scales one possibility for
perhaps healing the disagreements of
this model would be if one believes and
one does have some reason to believe
that there might be light neutrinos in
say the seven electron volt range such a
nutrient would not dominate the dark
matter of the universe it would not be
the dark matter the dark matter would
have to still be some other slowly
moving weakly interacting particle known
generically as cold dark matter but an
admixture of neutrinos would of course
give you an extra
it works exactly the direction that
would allow you to give more power at
large scales and less power at small
scales which seems to be what the
astronomical observations are pointing
towards so this model is still probably
the favorite of most model builders in
cosmology but several other models
remain open in particular number five
here an open model therefore
inconsistent with inflation but an open
model is nonetheless apparently
consistent with Kobe however it cannot
be an open model in which all the matter
is baryonic it's not the simple universe
that some people have advocated it's
still a universe in which more than half
of the matter is nonbaryonic it's the
only way you can get the initially small
density fluctuations to grow large
enough and finally what also works quite
well but from most particle theorists
regard this as distasteful there is a
possibility of having a cosmological
constant which makes up most of the
effective mass density of the universe
sometimes called vacuum energy and that
does fit the data
although most most theorists regard it
is implausible that the cosmological
constant should just happened to have a
value which is relevant to cosmology
thinking of it in particle physics terms
where it represents an energy of a
vacuum which need not have anything to
do with the cosmology so as you see the
results of Cobie are extremely exciting
and what I think is the most exciting
thing is that it's by no means finished
if Kobe is right a number of
ground-based balloon based experiments
are just on the verge of seeing
non-uniformities and the cosmic
background radiation and these in fact
will give us information on the very
interesting smaller scales the scales
which really are the scales from which
galaxies and clusters of galaxies form
and the Coby satellite itself will be
also giving us more data and since most
of the areas errors appear to be
statistical the error bars on the Kobe
data will come down very significantly
over the next year's
so what Kobe has done I think is to
really open a new era in astronomy we
now have a new form of astronomy the
astronomy of the fluctuations of the
microwave background and it has the
possibility of telling us a really large
amount of information about exactly how
our universe evolved thank you
you